[Music]
welcome to cloud on air the live
webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting webinars every Tuesday my name
is Elias Pinto I'm a customer engineer
in New York and today we're joined by
Prabhupada sunny from Spring ml we will
be talking about how to make your media
content discoverable and engaging for
folks on the line you can ask questions
any time on the platform and we have
Googlers on standby
to answer them so probably why don't you
tell us a little bit about yourself and
what you do at spring ml why don't you
take it away all right thanks Alice
hello everyone thanks for the
opportunity to present spring ml and
some of our machine learning use cases
we recently implemented for our
customers but the way of introduction my
name is Prabhu Palani Sami I'm one of
the cofounders at Spring ml I'm
delighted to give an intro of spring ml
and highlight some of the Google cloud
technologies from a machine learning
stamp our spring ml we started in 2015
and specializing in data analytics and
machine learning our two strategic
partners are Google and Salesforce we
specialize in couple of verticals are
namely media health care technology and
energy today we are gonna focus on media
and entertainment industry and showcase
some of the applications in machine
learning
from a capability standpoint spring ml
has deep deep integration and data
processing experience coupled with
machine learning and advanced data
analytics makes it ideal for enterprises
who have data intensive use cases from a
recognition standpoint spring ml is one
of the very few companies in the world
in the Google ecosystem that has machine
learning and data analytics
specialization here I'm gonna highlight
a couple of vertical domains that have
what I call data intensive use cases for
example energy has a lot of exploration
GPS related use cases healthcare on the
payer side provider
and of course media the the discussion
of the topic today generate a vast
amount of video files audio files and
image files on a daily basis
traditionally implementing insights
using machine learning for these large
datasets has been challenging with the
introduction of Google machine learning
api's and some of the frameworks makes
it easy for us to implement such
solutions to our enterprise customers in
a matter of days and not months quick
overview of a spring ml and how we serve
our customers spring ml provides
combination of applications and services
applications are lightweight frameworks
that have three built machine learning
models and associated functionalities
built in and from a services standpoint
we help customers to go through the
implementation cycle all the way from
strategy integration implementation and
continuing the virtuous cycle so what we
believe at Spring ml is a journey at
customers where we take them on a
journey of implementation and making
them successful in machine learning and
data analytics then to just quickly
summarize from a spring ml standpoint
spring ml is one of the premier partners
in the Google cloud ecosystem that has
specialization in data analytics and
machine learning now to come to the
topic of the discussion today if we look
at it digital assets grow on a daily
basis these are some of the steps that I
pull from Gartner research and other
agencies weigh data that is generated
today 90% of those data sets are now is
in a form of an image audio file or
video files chief scientists fulfill a
at Google at lipids it as dark matter of
the web
these are asserts that are under
analyzed now with the use of Google
machine learning API
I'm gonna go through a set of use cases
and demos that will highlight the the
implementation of these technologies and
how customers can take advantage and
build new source of revenue using these
media assets so let's break it down when
I mean by digital a search or a media
asset it could be one armoire or
combination of the above here it could
be an audiophile it could be a video
file it could be an image file and
customers traditionally look for type of
analysis for example a video file
customers look to do some transcription
associated with it find objects of
interest location a person or if there
is an audio attached to the video what
type of sentiment or what the
conversation is around as you may
imagine here there are multiple levels
of analysis here for example if we take
a video file how we can break it down
into frames analyze the frames find the
insights from the frames and in in
parallel do transcription find the text
the language associated with it and even
find objects of interest or even perform
optical character recognition or OCR for
example if there is a logo present in
the video what type of logo can I
recognize down to now walk through these
use cases
hopefully I your interest to to showcase
what type of media files and how to
analyze them let me walk through one by
one
for example image files customers are in
just interested in finding what type of
files image file it is and who is there
in the image can I read that image to
find insights from the from the a sir
same thing with video files if I have
long-running videos and I need to find
insights quickly how can I process them
and I'm a wide human labor the demo that
I'm going to show today
is going to be a long-running video
today if we were to process them it
requires a lot of human labour with the
use of machine learning api's and custom
tensorflow models and the Google cloud
technologies these processes cut down
the implementation and the processing
time similarly on the audio side how do
we do text transcription language
translation to variety of languages that
the speech API supports and how it
applies to certain use cases are useful
for auditing compliance and other use
cases that we see for our media and
entertainment customers so here I am
going to switch my screen and walk
through a couple of demos here is an
application that we built where users
can quickly upload audio file or a video
file and have the machine learning api's
quickly perform transcription and
translation and allow the users to work
on these in a collaborative manner
imagine a news a journalist collected
information in the field and has a rough
set of audio and needs to be
transcripted before having the editor
engaged today these workflows are
disjointed and requires a lot of
back-and-forth between the various team
members so here in this system allows
transcription to a variety of languages
that we support and from a user
perspective we make it very easy for a
user to select an audio file and get it
processed automatically so in this
example I just selected a file and the
system uploaded it into the Google
storage and under the hood it calls the
Google speech API and the natural
language processing API to start
deriving the results out of it so for
example here let me select an audio
five where we see the transcription and
the results of it and let me play for a
few seconds for to highlight a feature
and I'll add some commentary artificial
intelligence is transforming every
industry in manufacturing as you can see
here the results are provided and the
users can now use the playback
functionality and follow through the
transcription this is again useful for
news journalists editors to start
building the new stories similarly if I
have a large content and I need to go to
select keyword I can just click on a
specific keyword and allow the playback
to start from their video or images of
packages and extracts text in real time
if the text does not confirm say for
example now the transcription is
complete now I want to take advantage of
the Google Drive or the collaboration so
immediately the application has an
integration to Google Drive and Anna
just a click of a button the Google
document is available with the
transcription so now I can quickly share
include other members for collaboration
comments feedback etc as I just
mentioned the same application supports
other languages
here is a quick up audio feed that
process to an another language in this
case it's Hindi if we look at the
application of these type of use cases
one in the past the accuracy level of
transcription and translation has been
not up to the level for an
enterprise-grade deployment today with
the machine learning API is that Google
deployed for example speech-to-text the
accuracy level is so high people are
looking to deploy it for enterprise data
application
this type of use cases are useful for
media agencies anyone who is generating
content on a daily basis let me switch
to a another demo that highlights the
use of video intelligence API and some
of the custom tensorflow markers in this
demo I'm going to showcase how to
process long-running videos and extract
insights out of it
this is a video that is around three of
hours between Roger Federer and Stan
Wawrinka and the challenge here is can
be used machine learning to generate a
highlight and helps the editors to avoid
looking at long-running videos if you
look at a tennis game there are certain
things are our points in time that are
useful for editors for example when the
referee says match point or set point
the system knows that okay that's the
crucial point or our event in the game
similarly if there is a huge audience
uproar that also means that there that's
a crucial game point between the players
also from an editor standpoint is it a
long rally or is it as ace that will
also helpful from an editor standpoint
now if we look at it if we process this
three-hour video and provide these
interesting frames now the job of the
editor makes it easier to look for these
frames and quickly start putting
highlights together let me play a couple
of snapshots and I'll add my commentary
for example here I'm going to click a
link that highlights the audience
applause
[Applause]
so if you look here these are moments in
frames the editor now has quick
editorial features to start looking
these frames and maybe generate and
highlight out of similarly as I
mentioned when the referee says a
breakpoint or a match point is also
crucial for an editor to look for
Christ's face match points to more
breakpoints what we have also done is we
have listed the key frames for for the
users to understand what is there in
this long-running video for example here
I wanna see the frame that is ball on
the line I want to see whether it is the
long rally or a short learning
I wanna see if it is short rally here so
for example if I select a frame this
seems to be so if we look at it the
basis is first supervised learning we
sit with this subject matter expert and
identify what frames are useful to
capture and we apply machine learning
and make these insights available for
our users in a quick to consume fashion
if we look at it the same concept can be
applied for any type of videos from a
Content standpoint what are all the
frames that are of interest to me and
how can I apply machine learning to
automatically look for those frames
hopefully this is useful gives an
overview about video intelligence let me
switch to an another demo that
highlights our face recognition and
detection
here is a demo where we apply in
addition to read the intelligence API
and also vision API find you in the
frame if there is a face present and if
it is a frame that I can recognize find
some summary from in this case wiki page
let me quickly walk through the pipeline
and highlight or showcase the the demo
one and I'll play the video file so here
is the pipeline that looks from a demo
standpoint so we have raw video file we
process that using the video
intelligence API the video intelligence
API provides coordinates and face
related coordinates again from a each
frame standpoint meaning if there is a
face present and coordinates and the
frame details of the of it then what we
do is we pass it to that vision API and
find if it is a face that we can
recognize and if we are able to
recognize the face can I get some
summary details from Wikipedia so from a
pipeline standpoint multiple api's are
involved and the data data pipeline
makes the integration here much easier
because all we are doing here is a
couple of API integrations so let me
play the video for a few seconds and
allows some commentary in it the Tyrell
corporation
mr. deckerd dr. Alden Tyrell I don't get
a taro Commerce is our goal here at
Tyrell more human than human is our
motto so as you can see here as the
video of place we are able to use the
functionality of the intelligence API
split the video into multiple frames and
within the frame we are looking for
faces that the system can recognize and
as you can see here the moment the face
is recognized we are able to take a
snapshot out of it pass it through the
vision API and if it is a celebrity we
can find the details from the results
that are provided from the vision API
and we are able to make a call to
Wikipedia API to summarize the results
so now again four functionalities for
customers who are looking for face
detection and other location-based our
intelligence these type of use cases are
much easier to implement with the Google
Cloud ml framework as well as the APS
lastly I'm going to highlight demo of
vision API and how to do document
processing so if we look at it there are
a lot of documents that are structured
space like it could be an invoice
document it could be a purchase order
there are a lot of structural documents
that require human as well as other
workflow based integrations to either
insert it into a back-end system for
processing etc what if if we can use
Google vision API and see if we can
automate such processes for example in
this demo here let me show case how an
invoice can be automatically extract the
key fields using the vision API and say
integrated to a Salesforce system
this will be useful for users and avoid
and typing or use of other OCR
technologies from an external
integration standpoint so if you look
here let me start with the template
structured document so in this case it's
a structural template and can be used
with an API to extract some of the key
fields in this case name address and
dates etc from a processing standpoint
what happens here is this particular
document is being processed through
vision API and we look for entities like
say is there a name present is there a
date person and with the combination of
rules based coordinates based and
entities based we can extract key fields
easy the same concept if I apply to
invoice document it's a structured
document it has certain key fields that
I need to look for say for example
invoice date account numbers invoice
amount description etc we follow the
same pipeline process way we can pass it
to the vision API and now the vision API
can quickly give me the result software
now that if I'm able to extract these
entities I can integrate to my back-end
system for example send this to
Salesforce application hopefully that
gives you the overview of how to process
image files video files and applying
vision for OCR type use cases let me
switch back to my slide and cover a
couple of lessons learns best practices
are some of the considerations based on
our recent implementations as you can
see on the top if we can if we were to
look at machine learning for
unstructured data sets
there are Verity of use cases here we
can apply api's we can apply
a new functionality that Google released
called Auto ml useful for custom
training models
similarly there are ml kits now
available makes it mobile application
development much easier then the super
developer centric tensorflow
with a large community following where
we can build and deploy custom machine
learning models in addition to it there
are also other open-source tools and
community has built a lot of machine
learning libraries for use and
integration so if we look at it there
are a lot of options available there are
a pH there are models there are open
source frameworks etc some of the
considerations we have seen is one
defining the use user stories or
requirements this is no different from
any of the other project development or
implementation cash should be taken to
make sure that who the user is what type
of profile what's the business value
from an implementation standpoint and
some of the other infrastructure related
use cases for example authentication
security performance how the error
handling should be applied etc this is
where spring ml can provide the right
guidance and the implementation support
for the enterprise's similarly if we
look at it data is the core element in
deploying machine learning projects so
there and particularly in this case for
media assets data files are large so how
do we come up with a data pipeline from
an integration standpoint where do we
store the data how do we store the data
what type of structures that will help
from an analysis of these files then
finally the integration so for example
if I have a media file I analyze the
media file the machine learning
now what how does this particular
machine learning insights gets
integrated to the existing business use
case integration needs to be thought
through to make sure that the insights
that are derived are useful and
customers can make informed decisions
based on these insights and finally
migration how am I gonna process
historical data how am I gonna make sure
that the the past insights and the new
machine learning model can coexist the
last piece is once I have the use of
stories define the business alignment is
there once when I have my data side the
technology team is in alignment how the
automation piece of it at Spring MLB we
joked that machine learning development
is easy but the automation is super hard
so how are we going to deploy these
machine learning models automate them
and make the DevOps easier again Google
has come up with some of the frameworks
that makes it easy for example for
tensorflow model development there is a
framework called cube flow which uses
the kubernetes container model to make
devops much easier so from an
implementation standpoint we need to
make sure that the user stories are
defined the data side this cover and
then the automation side of it hopefully
that gives an insight into some of the
lessons learned now stay tuned for like
QA we'll be back in less than a minute
you
and
we are back well thank you Prabhu for
that presentation and demonstration so
during the demonstration we had some
folks submit some questions from the
audience
so we wanted to present some questions
to you and the first one here how long
does it take to implement one of these
projects is there an average duration
what can you tell us about that sure
that's a very good question Elias
where'd we get that from our customers
after there is a lot of interest on
machine learning there is obviously
there is a lot of hype associated with
it as well but when it comes to
implementation historically in given the
complexity and and the implementation
duration customers fear that it may be
intensive from a resource standpoint
with a very minimal result from the
project so what we take through our
customers is taking these projects in
sprint based agile incremental delivery
model we want to make sure we understand
the vision of the customer we want to
make sure we understand the the the
long-term goal and how the customer
wants to derive insights out of it then
we break it down into smaller pieces for
example one of the things that spring ml
is if we cannot show value of a machine
learning project in six weeks
then we are not defining the question
trouble so the demos and the projects
that I showed during the session have
most of those projects were completed in
six to eight weeks that doesn't mean
that I am oversimplifying it but at the
same time these projects doesn't have to
be implemented in a traditional
multi-year multi-man implementation so
we make sure we understand the vision
and come up with an implementation plan
that comprises of multiple sprints and
show
in each and every sprint schedule it's
so that way customers can take that
insight adopt it to the business process
let the feedback loop come in like
meaning what are the business users
saying are they finding value in it what
are the suggestions that they are
providing from the changes to the
machine learning model so we make sure
that the feedback loop comes back again
to the next print schedule and make sure
the machine learning models that we
build are to the customer requirements
and expectations thank you thank you we
have a couple more customer so an
audience member said I'm already in
another cloud can I still use machine
learning on Google Cloud perfect this is
again a great question
customers particularly large enterprises
have a variety of deployment methods and
if we look at the Google cloud machine
learning tool sets as I highlighted some
of the tool sets are API based that can
be invoked from multiple systems some of
the technologies are open source for
example tensorflow
and from a machine learning
implementation standpoint
depending on the asserts there are also
Hardware dependency to it for example
Google has a TPU based framework to
process large data sets image files etc
Google cloud also has GPUs to process
data intensive industries and if we look
at it that's the the foundation of
kubernetes to a certain extent where you
have containers and you build your
application deploy it in Cuba treaties
and depending on the platform or the
cloud of choice customer always have an
option so from our implementation
standpoint we make sure the customer
gets the advantages of the Google cloud
machine learning api's and leave the
option to the infrastructure team to the
deployment aspect of it Carrie
okay couple more
so what type of resources slash training
do I need on my team sounds like
somebody's wondering if they have to go
get a PhD so what kind of resources
training training do I need on my team
to do the machine learning perfect so
from a project implementation standpoint
this is again people fear that I need a
PhD or I need a data scientist or I need
some exceptional resources that are far
and few were scarce to find if we look
at it from a machine learning project or
data analytics standpoint the need for a
machine learning space is probably 10 to
15 percent of the whole project itself
so that's the core piece a core resource
needed but it is from the larger context
and point it's a small slice in the
implementation if we look at it in our
projects the data integration tend to be
much longer and much labor intensive
than actual machine learning development
itself and as folks know is the the
exercise of data cleaning data wrangling
data processing often times is much more
than actual machine learning development
itself so from a resource standpoint
some of the project related governance
are are have to be there so you need a
strong project manager a business
analyst a subject-matter expertise that
the customer knows what is that insider
and from an implementation technology
standpoint obviously a data scientist
and a data engineer or common resources
and particularly google cloud has done a
phenomenal job on the technology
information got capsule for example I am
a big fan of cloud owner myself where I
have learnt about kubernetes ml creates
the new technologies that are being
deployed from Google's Empire so from
the the feedback perspective resources
voice I would consider looking at from a
holistic project standpoint so as
as much as you need the data scientists
on the data engineer you also need to
have a project manager who understands
what went through from a machine
learning standpoint and also a subject
matter expert business analyst who can
communicate the business users to the
data scientists and engineers good I
thought I'd get a PhD good thank you we
have our last seems like to be last
question so how do you scale the
processes and to end yes this is again
one of the areas with a probably project
team or the implementation team does not
see it through the end like as I
mentioned that often times machine
learning development is easy but the
operationalizing part of it is super
hard so from the processes standpoint
how do you scale into it so the
infrastructure side of it need to be
thought through and also from the
business side of it as I said that
feedback loop is very important like am
I seeing value am i deriving the value
out of it and accordingly make the
production deployment elastic today with
the introduction of containers I don't
need to have a scale of processing
hundred nodes all the time you come up
with a model you deploy it if the best
business users like it if the customers
are liking it they are deriving the
value scale on a need basis and with the
kubernetes coop flow and some of the
container based implementation it makes
it easier so you can start small for
example some of the projects that we
showcase often has large data sets for
example a three-hour tennis video is
quickly run into jeebies similarly other
media companies so if we wait to set up
on infrastructure on the get-go
it may look monumental rather we can
start small scale and use the Google
cloud functionalities most of the Google
cloud product suites for example App
Engine
my kubernetes allowed to do elastic
scaling make sure that infrastructure
team is aware of it and and the
configuration set in a way you can start
not scale based on feedback and
obviously with Google cloud some of the
resources are infinite scale right so we
we built a data center already you don't
need to build another one excellent
excellent
I think that's all for the questions
that we have today so for the folks
online please stay tuned we have another
session coming up and it's titled 99
problems but GPU ain't one
it sounds like a fun one so again my
name is Elias and Prabhu here and we
thank you for your participation with
questions and until next time
[Music]
you